und jetzt das heute journal
einen schönen guten Abend es ist ein
Wochenende der Entscheidungen morgen
klärt sich in einer Stichwahl in der
Türkei wer das Land zukünftig regieren
wird darüber berichten wir gleich heute
hat sich bereits im Fußball geklärt wer
aufsteigt absteigt und vor allen Dingen
wer Deutscher Meister wird für Dortmund
war im Grunde alles angerichtet der BVB
hatte die Chance aus eigener Kraft und
vor der gelben Wand den Titel zu Hause
zu holen doch stadttitel gab's Trauer
und Tränen nicht nur das Trainers die
Schale geht also stattdessen zum
insgesamt 33 mal an den FC Bayern
München aber auf den Erfolg folgte kommt
ein personelles Leben was ist damit auf
sich hat und wie das und hier passt das
Wort mal Herzschlagfinale lief Stefan
Bier
die Bayern feiern die Bayern feuern das
mit dem Feiern kommt durch den 2:1
Siegtreffer in der 89 Minute in Köln
durch den kurz zuvor eingewechselten
Jamal musiala zustande das Tor zur
Meisterschaft als wir gesehen haben dass
der Ball ins Eck reingeht das schon mal
zieht ab und geht ins Eck rein was da
für einen Stromschlag durchsteigen also
so würde ich es beschreiben durch den
Körper geht
Sportvorstand hast dann sehr mitchic
feiert noch mit 1 Stunde später steht
fest er muss gehen nach einer insgesamt
schwachen Saison mit umstrittenem
Trainerwechsel die auch Bayern Vorstand
Oliver Kahn der nicht in Köln ist der
Verein wollte das so sagt der später die
Bayern tauschen ihr führungsduro aus
während sie den 11 Titel nacheinander
feiern
[Applaus]
daheim in München ist das erstmal egal
es war aufregend genug
Wahnsinn es Wahnsinn also
man hat es nicht mehr geglaubt
zwischendurch ja gerade nach dieser
Saison in Köln müssen die Bayern noch am
Handy das Dortmund Spiel abwarten bevor
Sie sicher sein können denn Dortmund
macht in letzter Minute noch das 22
gegen Mainz aber für den Sieg Treffer
reicht's nicht mehr das schlechtere
Torverhältnis bringt sie um den Titel
es ist hart wenn man wenn man sieht das
am Ende ein Tor fehlt sowohl hier als
auch dann in Köln und
dann noch der verschossene Elfmeter und
die Vielzahl der Chancen und das deshalb
das fällt schwer ist gab kein Happy End
für uns für diese Saison und
es tut extrem weh wie auch nebenan auf
Schalke 2 zu 3 in Leipzig verloren sich
steigen ab es kommt eine traurige Zeit
auf diesen Teil des Fußball Ruhrpotts zu
also auf der einen Seite Trauer und
Tränen auf der anderen Seite Titel und
Schale aber auch das nächste
kommunikationsdesaster bei den Bayern
gibt also viel zu bereden gleich im
Aktuellen Sportstudio direkt im
Anschluss an das heute schon mal jetzt
zum nächsten Showdown dem in der Türkei
da hatten bei der Wahl vor zwei Wochen
viele nicht Erdogan Anhänger auf eine
Art Zeitenwende gehofft wenn sich sechs
Parteien aus unterschiedlichen Lagern
zusammen tun dann muss doch der
Präsident zu besiegen sein so die
Hoffnung der
oppositionellen daraus wurde bekanntlich
nichts nicht mal annähernd Erdogan lag
am Ende 4,6% Punkte vor seinem
Herausforderer und so glauben viele bei
der Stichwahl morgen nicht mehr an ein
Wunder während für manche Erdogan das
Wunder ist
Leute Collie Bomber für seine Anhänger
ist Recep Tayyip Erdogan nicht nur ihr
Staatspräsident nein sie beten ihn an
wie einen heiligen Gül deiner Öztürk und
ihre Freundinnen sind besehlt was er für
ihr Land getan habe die Liste sei endlos
sagt sie
[Musik]
früher sind wir aufgestanden und haben
darüber gestritten wer heute dran ist
den Dreck vor der Haustür aufzukehren
und jetzt jetzt stehen wir auf und der
Dreck vor der Tür ist schon längst
aufgeklärt das sehen wir erst seit er
unser Land führt
das Erdogan mit der ganzen Macht und dem
Geld seines Amtes in den Wahlkampf zieht
seine Anhänger stört das nicht im
Gegenteil gelte ist doch das Land vor
Terroristen zu schützen mit denen sein
Herausforderer angeblich Packtiere
dieser Handschlag Kiel in der Rollos mit
der Führung der Pro kurdischen HDP
liefert Erdogan die Munition die HDP sei
der verlängerte Armen kurdischer
Terroristen behauptet
Eru hat seinerseits verbal aufgerüstet
Terror wird beendet die Inflation
gesenkt die Syrer nach Hause geschickt
Härte statt versöhnlicher Worte und der
schließt einen Pakt mit einer
Nationalisten Partei wird um
konservative Stimme auf Rollos frontal
Angriff reagiert die Staatsmacht mit der
Blockade seiner Werbekampagne per SMS
der Kandidat ist außer sich
ich frage dich Erdogan soll ich auf die
Wahlen verzichten so kann man in der
Türkei keine Wahlen abhalten dieser Mann
ist ein Feigling wegen dir wird dieses
Land draufgehen was hast du vor mit
diesem Land du Feigling
der Präsident gibt sich unbeeindruckt
fordert seine Anhänger auf unbedingt
morgen noch mal wählen zu gehen güldene
Öztürk und ihre Freundinnen werden das
tun wollen ihrem Heilsbringer zum Sieg
verhelfen und zum Triumph über Kemal
kilica
wir schicken Ihnen Rente soll er sich
freuen dass wir ihn in Rente schicken
auf Wiedersehen
abgerechnet aber wird erst morgen nach
17 Uhr deutscher Zeit auch wenn viele
meinen das Rennen sei längst gelaufen
ist für uns in Istanbul Jörg schönen
guten Abend warum glauben dass denn
viele dass das Rennen schon gelaufen ist
bei dieser Vorsprung von 5% doch eben
sehr groß war und wenn Erdogan es
schafft seine religiös konservativen und
vor allem nationalistischen Wählern und
morgen noch mal an die Uhren zu bringen
dann rechnen doch viele damit das ist
wieder ein solchen Vorsprung geben
könnte damit rechnet wohl auch sein
Wahlkampf Team und hat heute
überraschend den Ort für seine Balkon
Rede verschoben diese Rede hält er
normalerweise in der Wahlnacht wenn die
Ergebnisse einigermaßen feststehen vor
seinen Unterstützern vom Balkon der
Parteizentrale seine ak-parteien Ankara
und die soll er nun morgen vom Balkon
des Präsidentenpalastes heilt halten das
heißt entweder glaubt man dass er auch
weiterhin dort residieren wird in jedem
Falle aber ist das eine Macht der
monsterstation ist denn der Kampf
zwischen dem Präsidenten und dem
Herausforderer einer auf sagen wir mal
Augenhöhe was Mittel und Methoden
anbelangt
nein das ist es nicht die Opposition
bekommt kaum Sendezeiten den von der
Regierung kontrollierten Staatsmedien
sie hatten massive Probleme ihre
Botschaften rüber zu bekommen das wird
doch immer wieder kritisiert von
internationalen Beobachtern aber diese
Kritik die tropft dann Präsidenten und
seiner Regierung ab genau so wie die
Kritik darin dass massiv öffentliche
Gelder in Erdogans Wahlkampf gepumpt
werden der schwebt auch gerne mal mit
seinem Trost in zwei oder drei großen
regierungsmaschinen bei
Wahlkampfveranstaltungen im Land ein und
so sagt die Opposition dann wir kämpfen
ja nicht gegen einen Kandidaten wir
kämpfen gegen die ganze Regierung und im
Grunde kämpfen wir gegen den Staat sagt
der Phase live aus Istanbul vielen Dank
für heute und bis morgen
und wir kommen jetzt zu den
deutsch-russischen Beziehungen die sind
ja schon sehr belastet Gundula und jetzt
gibt es da sogar noch mal neue
Irritation hunderte deutsche
Staatsbürger müssen Russland verlassen
die Regierung in Moskau hat für das
Personal deutsche Einrichtungen laut
Auswärtigen Amt eine Obergrenze
eingeführt betroffen sind deutsche
Diplomaten Lehrer der deutschen Schule
und Mitarbeitende der Goethe-Institute
das sei einseitig und nicht
nachvollziehbar so die Kritik aus Berlin
Moskau behauptet auf vergleichbare
deutsche Schritte zu reagieren
nach den Unruhen im Kosovo dass sich von
Serbien vor Jahren gelöst hatte hat
Serbiens Präsident Vucic die Armee in
Bereitschaft versetzt und Soldaten an
die Grenze zum Kosovo geschickt dort war
es gestern erneut zu Ausschreitungen
zwischen Serben und Albanern gekommen
mehrere westliche Staaten darunter
Deutschland äußerten sich besorgt
die niederländische Polizei hat bei
einer Demonstration von
klimaaktivisten in Den Haag fast
1.600 Menschen festgenommen aus Protest
gegen die Energiepolitik der Regierung
hatten etwa 3000 Aktivisten zum siebten
Mal eine Autobahn nahe des Parlaments
blockiert diese Aktion hatten die
Behörden untersagt
ein Mann
dessen Leben und Lebenserfahrungen kaum
in einer Handvoll Bücher passt wird
heute 100 Jahre alt aber wenn man sich
anschaut und anhört was Henry Kissinger
noch alles zur aktuellen Krisen und
Kriegen zu sagen hat dann würde man eher
sagen er wird 100 Jahre jung sein Leben
ist eine lange Reise als Deutscher
immigrant steigt der in den USA zum
nationalen Sicherheitsberater auf wird
dann sogar aus dem Minister er machte
Geschichte und er mochte macht dafür
ginge auch im Vietnamkrieg über Leichen
sagen seine Kritiker Elma teven über ein
Mann der scheinbar nicht zur Ruhe kommt
und viele seiner Freunde wie Feinde
überlebt hat
sie feiern ihn schon ein wenig vor den
Mann der immer noch klarer Ansagen macht
gerade erst an Vladimir Putin in Moskau
nichts entschuldigt das Ausmaß und die
Methoden mit denen Russland diesen Krieg
führt
geboren wird Heinrich Alfred Kissinger
1923 hinführt 1938 flieht seine jüdische
Familie vor den Nazis sechs Jahre später
kehrte als US-Soldat zurück ist
beteiligt am Wiederaufbau der
Zivilverwaltung ein Brückenbauer wird
Ehrenbürger der Stadt führt unsere
beiden Völker
sind vom batherine Konflikt zum Frieden
und vom Frieden zur Versöhnung und zu
gemeinsamen Streben geschritten
Präsident Nixen heute in Historiker und
Politikwissenschaftler ins Zentrum der
Macht kissenger mischt brilliante
Analyse mit gnadenlosem Pragmatismus ein
Realpolitiker der alle Ideologien
verachtet unter seinem Einfluss beginnen
die Supermächte im Kalten Krieg mit der
Entspannungspolitik auch die deutsche
Ostpolitik liegt ganz auf seiner Linie
seine Unterschrift besiegelt das Ende
des Vietnamkriegs Jahres später als es
möglich gewesen wäre sagen Kritiker
Jahre mit hunderttausenden tot trotzdem
bekommt Kissinger den Friedensnobelpreis
auch dafür warnt er mit seiner geheimen
Diplomatie den Weg Richard Nixon
historischer Besuch bei mauzedong
Tauwetter in den Beziehungen zwischen
China und den USA
auch nach seiner Amtszeit sucht
Kissinger das Gespräch mit unliebsamen
Machthabern im jetzigen Krieg fordert er
Friedensgespräche am besten nach einer
erfolgreichen ukrainischen Offensive
die Ukraine sollte dann auch Mitglied
der NATO werden um sie vor künftigen
russischen Angriffen zu schützen
klare Verhältnisse und Garantien für
beide Seiten weiser Rat an seinem
hundertsten Geburtstag
[Musik]
happy Birthday die deutsche Eishockey
Nationalmannschaft steht zum ersten Mal
seit 93 Jahren im Finale einer
Weltmeisterschaft und hat damit ihre
erste WM-Medaille seit 70 Jahren sicher
nachdem Sieg gegen die USA geht es im
Finale gegen Kanada mehr gleich im
aktuellen Sportstudium die gewinnzahlen
vom Lotto wie immer ohne Gewähr 3 7 12
18 28 34 ist Superzahl 4 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF
Text
das Wetter an diesem Pfingstwochenende
bleibt überwiegend trocken und bis in
die nächste Woche hinein sommerlich warm
im Norden ein freundlicher Sonne Wolken
Mix auch an den Alpen gibt es einige
Quellwolken sonst wolkenlos bei im
Norden 16 bis 21 und im Süden 21 bis 27
Grad auch in die nächsten Tagen bleibt
es sonnig mit meist nur wenigen Wolken
und Temperaturen bis 27 Grad
gute Aussichten kommen wir zum letzten
Showdown für heute den
filmfestspielenden kann und der Frage
wer hat sie bekommen die wichtigen
Preise insbesondere für den besten Film
die beste Schauspielerin und den besten
Schauspieler zwei deutsche so viel
seiferaten haben indirekt gewonnen von
der 76 Verleihung Anna wassberg
die Goldene Palme sie geht am System
tree für Anatomie dünnschild mit der
deutschen Sandra Hülle in der Hauptrolle
in Anatomie den Anatomie eines Sturzes
spielt Hülle eine deutsche Autorin nach
dem Tod ihres Mannes muss die sich vor
Gericht verantworten es geht um Schuld
Trauer und die Grenze zwischen Fiktion
und Realität klar in Team feinfühlig
ist keine Verkehrs der Applaus hört
nicht auf und die französische
Regisseurin muss sich erstmal fassen es
folgt ihre politische Botschaft gegen
die Auswirkung der französischen
Rentenreform
die Kommerzialisierung der Kultur die
die neoliberale Regierung verfolgt
zerstört gerade die Einzigartigkeit der
französischen Kultur zum besten
männlichen Schauspieler wird der
japanert in Wim Wenders perfect days
spielt er einen Toilettenreiniger in
Japan und spricht kaum schafft es fast
alle Emotionen seiner Figur hieraryama
mit den Augen und mal einem Lächeln zu
zeigen liebevoll ruhig
ich muss Wim Wenders und dem Co-Autor
danken ihr habt mit herajama eine
fantastische Figur geschaffen
das 76 Filmfestival war auch dieses Jahr
wieder die Bühne der großen Filme Macher
der finnische Regisseur aki kaurismärki
ist seinem Stil treu geblieben mit
vollen leaves eine pastellfarbene
verworrende Liebesgeschichte voller
Melancholie dafür bekommt er heute Abend
in Jury-Preis
es waren viele nachdenkliche Filme die
nicht dick auftragen viel ruhiges im
Kinosaal während draußen internationale
Extravaganz und Glamour 12 Tage lang
kann blendend streiten
[Musik]
es ist sogar der intimste Film den sie
je gemacht hat sagt die französische
Filme Macherin über Anatomie eines Falls
und Sandra Hüller muss man sagen ist
immer ein Kino besucht werden
alles vom Sport jetzt gleich im
Sportstudio mit Sven Voss und wir sehen
uns dann hier morgen wieder machen sie
es gut wo auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]